good morning John I'm at the grocery
store right now with Michael or Rhonda
because we are going to be playing some
Hunger Games in honor of the release of
The Hunger Games welcome to the
first-ever Hank and Michael Hunger Game
that shall be several components to this
year's Hunger Games different games
within games just go get this go away
Clark number one Michael and I have not
eaten anything and it's like four
o'clock in the afternoon so we are hung
second Hunger part of Hunger Games
Hungry Hungry Hippos which is a hunger
game and the third part of the Hunger
Games we are making cookies but we are
making them weird we are putting a
different thing inside of every cookie
and there will be two files a good pile
and a bad pile if you lose you have to
eat from the bad pile in the good pile
we have gushers banana a piece of a Twix
bar some york peppermint pattie Lucio's
a miniature Oreo or chocolate Reese's
Peanut Butter Cup and John's favorite a
peep yeah there's like milk chocolate on
their butts I'm sure we're gonna have to
decapitate them if you didn't cookie
anyway even the bad pile we have beef
jerky cold cuts and barbecue sauce
yellow mustard easy cheese Oh pickles
sooner Pringles a hard-boiled egg or
some potted meat food product yeah
that's the one I'm looking forward to
this is our chocolate chip cookie dough
never eat raw cookie dough because it's
bad for you the way to do what I think
is to like take some cookie dough and
then you like make a bowl and then you
put your thing you do the bowl and then
you close the bowl up it just looks like
a cookie so you can't tell what's in
there so it would be a surprise it's
gonna remove his head
is not going to be a calorie neutral day
why don't you like all the sink and I'm
like because they taste like poison keep
home look at your fingers before you
make more cookies that I'm going to
repeat
we have made cookies we have the good
and no bad and the good I could tell
because I saw some egg oh really bad
broke can't wait to see what I get an X
it looks like don't try this at home
because it's stuck to the baking sheet
like mad but chocolate chip and gushers
cookies a plus
[Music]
the texture more than anything
alright barbecued turkey cookie come to
me nope nope nope nope nope we are no
longer hungry
in fact I am now what you would call the
opposite of hungry instead wanting to
put food in my body I would like to take
it out which end either thank you for
watching the first annual Hunger Games
this is an annual thing I'm I have to do
this again we are aware of the
metaphorical implications of what we've
just done John I'll see you on Tuesday